Researchers have discovered jellyfish sleep
and have the same trouble we do waking up.
Since jellyfish are very low
on the animal family tree,
the work suggests that the ability to sleep
evolved quite early.
So how can you tell an animal is napping
not just resting or in a coma?
For one, we are unresponsive to gentle nudging
or soft sounds
but wake up immediately if we fall out of bed
or hear a loud enough noise.
If we cut our sleep short,
we are groggy the next day,
and sleep more soundly when we finally
do get to bed.
Researchers decided to see if a jellyfish,
whose nervous system isn’t centralized and
doesn’t include a brain—could sleep.
They looked at several species of upside-down jellyfish
in the genus Cassiopea,
which often hangs out
facing upward – instead of downward
Like corals but unlike most jellyfish,
Cassiopea host algae in their bodies
that help supply nutrients.
They pulse their bells once per second,
keeping water flowing over their bodies
to sweep in food and clear away waste.
The researchers monitored the pulsing of 23 animals,
day and night, for almost a week.
During the day, the jellies pulsed ~60 times/min
At night, the jellyfish slowed to ~39 pulses.
To see if they were really asleep,
the researchers lifted them off the bottom of the tanks
and measured how quickly they started
swimming back to the bottom.
Like a groggy person slow to get moving in the morning,
the jellyfish were slow to respond.
But they did wake up--
if they were lifted again 30 secs later,
they swam immediately down to the bottom.
Finally, when some jellyfish were deprived of sleep,
they were not as active the next morning—
-- but recovered the next day.
That sleeping evolved in these animals suggests that
it’s not just that brains need sleep,
but that individual nerve cells may as well.
It might also mean that sleep was present
in the very first animals to exist on the planet.